[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing books
versus films honing in on some of the
darkest book moments that for varying
reasons simply never made their way onto
the Silver Screen while the film
adaptations brought the magic of
Hogwarts to life on the big screen they
were not without their limitations in
the process of adapting the complex and
intricate world of the books into a more
visually driven medium certain dark and
unsettling moments were omitted or
altered leaving fans with a somewhat
diluted version of Rowling's original
Vision today we'll delve into these dark
moments left out of the films exploring
the reasons behind their omissions and
the impact of these changes on the
overall story let's dive in 10.
grayback's darkest instincts fenrick
Grayback is undoubtedly a malevolent
character as a werewolf and pseudo Death
Eater he Revels in assaulting his
victims and follows Lord Voldemort's
orders without hesitation and for the
most part grayback's dark nature is
showcased pretty well on screen however
there is a moment from the bugs which
occurs at Malfoy Manor where we're
forced to look at greybag through an
even darker lens after being captured by
snatchers Hermione Ron and Harry find
themselves in a dangerous situation
among the captors is Fenway Grayback
grayback's interaction with Hermione at
Malfoy Manor is a tense and disturbing
moment as he takes an unsettling
interest in her which is consistent with
his sadistic Tendencies during this
moment greyback not only talks about
wanting to eat her but also implies that
he might have other plans for her 9.
Winky's addiction issues winky the
household for the sorrowful life filled
with hardships and a tragic butterbeer
addiction originally she served the
Crouch family loyally taking care of
Barty Crouch Jr while he was under the
imperious curse however when Mr Crouch
suspected winky of conspiring with his
son to cast the dark mark at the
Quidditch World Cup he dismissed her
from their service this dismissal was a
devastating blow to winky as house elves
are deeply attached to their families
and rely on their masters for a sense of
purpose and belonging following her
dismissal winky was employed at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry but
her heartbreak and loss of purpose led
her to develop an addiction to
butterbeer the drink which has a minimal
effect on humans is considerably more
potent for our house elves which caused
winky to become intoxicated and
emotionally unstable she spent much of
her time at Hogwarts in a state of
despair drowning her sorrows in
butterbeer unable to recover from the
trauma of losing her family as winky was
omitted from the films entirely her sad
story never made its way under the
Silver Screen winky is getting through
six bottles a day now Dobby whispered to
Harry well it's not strong that stuff
Harry said but Dobby shook his head to
his strong for house self sir he said
eight Death Eaters torture Muggles the
Death Eater attack on the Quidditch
World Cup in Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire is Rife with chaos after a
thrilling match between Ireland and
Bulgaria a group of Voldemort's
followers launched a surprise assault on
the campsite where Wizards and witches
are celebrating during this attack they
cause chaos and destruction terrorizing
attendees however one particularly dark
component of this event left out of the
films was the torturous attack on a
group of innocent Muggles the Roberts
family a crowd of wizards tightly packed
and moving together with ones pointing
straight upward was marching slowly
across the field Harry squinted at them
they didn't seem to have faces then he
realized that their heads were hooded
and their faces masked high above them
floating along in mid-air four
struggling Figures were being contorted
into grotesque shapes it was as though
the masked wizard on the ground were
puppeteers and the people above them
were marionettes operated by invisible
strings that Rose from the wands into
the air two of the Figures were very
small seven Neville's parents Neville's
parents aren't mentioned that often in
the films and they also sort of lead us
to believe that they had been killed by
Bellatrix however book readers will know
that this is not the case in the Order
of the Phoenix the trio ran into Neville
and his grandmother at Saint munger's
hospitals for magical Melody and
injuries it's here that it's revealed
that Neville's parents are in fact alive
but were just driven insane through
bellatrix's horrific torture in
heartbreaking fashion Neville would go
and visit his parents every Christmas to
spend the day with them despite them
barely recognizing who he is one of the
most heartbreaking moments is when we
witness Alice Neville's mum giving him a
candy wrapper as a gift she did not seem
to want to speak or perhaps she was not
able to but she made timid motions
toward Neville holding something in her
outstretched hand again said Mrs
Longbottom sounding slightly wary very
well Alice dear very well level take it
whatever it is but Neville had already
stretched out his hand into which his
mother dropped an empty drupal's blowing
gum wrapper very nice dear to Neville's
grandmother in a falsely cheery voice
patting his mother on the shoulder but
Neville said quietly thanks mum 6. Tom
Riddle killing his family over the
course of the Half-Blood Prince the true
story of Tom Riddle unfolds revealing
his dark past and the murder of his
family in little hangleton born to a
muggle Father Tom Riddle senior and a
witch mother therapy gaunt Tom Riddle
grew up in an orphanage after his
mother's death and his father's
abandonment as he discovered his magical
abilities and Heritage he developed a
deep hatred for his father and the
Muggle side of his family upon learning
about his family's location Tom Riddle
now a Hogwarts student visited little
hangleton to confront his father and
grandparents in a cold-blooded Act of
Revenge he is the killing curse to
murder them the police had never read an
odd a report a team of doctors had
examine the bodies and had concluded
that none of the riddles had been
poisoned stabbed shot strangled
suffocated or as far as they could tell
harmed at all in fact the report
continued in a turn of unmistakable
bewilderment there all appeared to be in
perfect health apart from the fact that
they were all dead the doctors did note
as though determined to find something
wrong with the bodies that each of the
riddles had a look of Terror upon his or
her face but as the frustrated police
said whoever heard of three people
frightened to death
5. Harry's change of heart the first
time Harry Potter tries to use crucio
it's pretty ineffective after Bellatrix
Lestrange kills Sirius Black Harry
chases after Bellatrix and attempts to
torture her with the infamous curse
however the curse is largely ineffective
due to the fact that Harry didn't really
mean it this scene is included in the
films now Harry wasn't an evil person
and he didn't derive any kind of Joy
from torturing people which is why the
curse didn't work however there is a
moment in the books omitted from the
films where Harry is able to use the
curse effectively revealing a darker
side of Harry and what he was capable of
after all that he had endured in the
Years prior Harry pulled the cloak off
himself raised it to one and said you
shouldn't have done that as Amica spun
around Harry shouted crucio the Death
Eater was lifted off his feet he writhed
through the air like a drowning man
thrashing and Howling in pain and then
with the crunch in shattering of glass
he smashed into the front of a bookcase
and crumpled insensible to the floor I
see what Bellatrix meant said Harry the
blood thundering through his brain you
need to really mean it 4. Barty Crouch
Jr.'s imprisonment and I'm not talking
about Azkaban body Crouch Jr is best
known for impersonating Aleister Moody
over the course of the Goblet of Fire
however he has a substantial backstory
that seemed to be entirely glossed over
in the films brought his appearance in
the Goblet of Fire Crouch Jr had been
sentenced to Azkaban for his crimes
during the first Wizarding War his
mother a forgiving woman that found out
that she was dying convinced to crouch
senior to help her bail their son out of
Azkaban using polyju's potion and put
her in his place the crouches were
successful in their Endeavor however the
tension between father and son wasn't
going anywhere after his Escape bati
senior kept the younger bati under his
control by way of the imperious curse on
the rare event the bharti senior would
allow his son out in public he kept him
concealed under an invisibility cloak
after being kept in the Locking key for
over a decade Barty Jr was basically
insane at this point and I think it's
safe to assume that his mental state was
likely a culmination of his father's
neglect while growing up the fact that
he was put on trial and sentenced to
life in prison by his own father the
time he spent in Azkaban under the
depressing influence of the Dementors
and his father's mental imprisonment of
him through the imperious curse body
Crouch Jr was undoubtedly an evil wizard
that deserved some level of imprisonment
but I think that his father keeping
control of him via the imperious curse
for a decade was simply a step too far
three Molly Weasley's pocket in the
Order of the Phoenix were given a
glimpse into the deepest fears of Molly
Weasley the loving and fiercely
protective matriarch of the Weasley
family do her encounter with the bogert
while cleaning number 12 gremold Place
Molly Weasley comes face to face with a
bogert that transforms one by one into
the lifeless bodies of her loved ones
revealing Molly's greatest fear the
death of her family members the bocket
Cycles through several forms including
her husband Arthur her children Bill
Charlie Percy Fred George Ron and Ginny
and even Harry Potter whom she considers
as one of her own no Mrs Weasley moaned
no ridiculous ridiculous ridiculous and
crack dead twins crack did Percy crack
dead Harry Mrs Weasley just get out of
here shouted Harry this heartbreaking
scene offers a deeper insight into
Molly's character showcasing her
profound love and concern for her
family's well-being as a mother and wife
during a time of great turmoil in The
Wizarding World Molly is painfully aware
of the dangers that her family faces 2.
Peter petticoot's death in the seventh
book The Deathly Hallows Pettigrew meets
his end during the Battle of Malfoy
Manor this event takes place when Harry
Ron and Hermione are captured and held
prisoner in the cellar of the Malfoy
family's estate in the films pettigrew's
fate is left very unclear but in the
books for given a clear picture of his
brutal death the silver fingers
slackened Harry had not expected it he
wrenched himself free astonished keeping
his hand of the wormtail's mouth he saw
the rat like man's small watery eyes
widened with fear and surprise he seemed
just as shocked as Harry at what his
hand had done at the tiny merciful
impulse that had betrayed and he
continued to struggle more powerfully as
though too undo that moment of weakness
and will have that whispered Ron tugging
worm tells one from his other hand
wandless helpless pedicure's pupils
dilated in Terror his eyes had slid from
Harry's face to something else his own
silver fingers were moving inexorably
toward his own throat no without pausing
to think Harry tried to drag back the
hand but there was no stopping it the
silver tool that Voldemort had given his
most cowardly servant had turned upon
its disarmed and useless owner Pettigrew
was reaping his reward for his
hesitation his moment of pity he was
being strangled Before Their Eyes no Ron
had released wormtale 2 and together he
and Harry tried to pull the crushing
metal fingers from a roundworm towel's
throat but it was no use battery was
turning blue relatio said Ron pointing
the wand at the silver hand but nothing
happened Pettigrew dropped to his knees
and at the same moment Hermione gave a
dreadful scream from overhead wormtel's
eyes rolled upward in his purple face he
gave a last twitch and was still 1.
Weasley twin torture Ron's older
brothers Fred and George are mischievous
twin brothers known for their pranks and
light-hearted Antics however in the
Order of the Phoenix they take things
way too far when they lock a Slytherin
student named Montague in the vanishing
cabinet for several weeks the incident
occurs when Montague working for the
inquisitorial Squad tries to take points
away from Gryffindor for their
rule-breaking behavior in retaliation
Fred and George forced him into the
broken Vanishing cabinet intending to
teach him a lesson however the prank
takes a dark turn when Montague becomes
trapped inside the cabinet for weeks
unable to escape or communicate with the
outside world Montague told me that when
he was stuck in the Hogwarts one he was
trapped in limbo but sometimes he could
hear what was going on at school and
sometimes what was going on in the shop
as if the cabinet was traveling between
them but he couldn't make anyone hear
him and the end he managed to operate
out even though he never passed his test
he nearly died doing it during his
confinement Montague suffers from
extreme physical and emotional distress
nearly dying in the process he
eventually manages to escape by using a
combination of apparition and sheer
desperation despite not knowing where he
was or how to operate properly this
results in him being severely injured
reappearing within the Hogwarts plumbing
system and requiring extensive medical
attention and that's it for this video
did you guys know about all of these
dark moments from the books which one is
the darkest which dark moments would you
have included please leave a comment
down below if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher what not to do how not to
be